okay welcome everybody my name is
ricardo vinosa
i'm an associate professor at kth in
stockholm and today i'm going to tell
you how we can use machine learning to
try to improve computational free
dynamics
this is actually a study that we
recently published together with steve
branton in nature computational science
here is the reference and what we show
you is that you can use machine learning
for three main things so one can use
machine learning to try to accelerate
direct numerical simulations one can
also use machine learning to try to
improve modeling basically in the
context of
less and runs and finally one can use
machine learning to try to obtain more
robust reduce order models and that's
the topic that we're going to be
discussing today so we're going to zoom
in and try to understand a bit better
how machine learning can help in the
context of rom development for turbulent
flows
essentially
we can start with pod proper zonal
decomposition
which is a very well known and
established method to produce reduced
order models in the context of fluid
mechanics
this
decomposition has two nice properties
one is optimality which means that our
modes are going to be ranked from more
to less contribution towards the
reconstruction of the authorinal signal
and also the second property is the
orthogonality which will in principle
help with interpretability of these
modes and with developing more
parsimonious models so what we want to
do in this work and this is work
together with hamid resivassi you can
find the reference over here this is
published in the
journal expert systems with applications
we want to
retain those properties of optimality
and orthogonality while being able to
have a non-linear model decomposition of
complex turbulent flows
so that's what i'm going to be
discussing a bit more with you today
we're going to use this database so this
is a
very well resolved high fidelity
simulation of the turbulent flow between
two obstacles so we actually have a
quite complete database where we have a
number of obstacles and matrices and
arrays
in this case we just took the simplest
case which is in a scheming flow
configuration and
what we show here is that we can analyze
the 2d plane at the center right between
the two obstacles right at the middle of
the two obstacles um and what we will do
is that we will be able to
leverage what we know about item
encoders to try to understand a bit
better
the properties that one can embed to
have a nice and robust reduced model
so basically
we're going to start by showing you
another encoder and i'm sure many of the
people in the audience
know about these techniques these are
deep learning methods in which we can
progressively reduce the dimension of
the of the original signal
and as you can see
here at the middle you have the latent
space which basically constitutes a
compressed representation of the
original data and then that first step
is what we call the encoder and going
from the original space to the latent
space
now when we are in the latent space we
can use a decoder to recover the
original signal and therefore be able to
um well to to obtain that compressed
version of our
dataset
now autoencoders are
interesting because of course they're
based on deep learning they are
producing nonlinear
[Music]
compressed versions of the original data
the biggest problem is that they are not
optimal nor orthogonal and those are two
things that are interesting when it
comes to interpretability and uh
parsimonious representations of our
original system so what we will be doing
is that we are going to try to
understand how to impose these
properties
and an interesting word by
fukami and others this is koi fukuratas
group
is based on hierarchical autoencoders so
the hierarchical autoencoders
are aiming at
imposing this property of the optimality
so you start with an first out encoder
as you can see here which has a
dimension one in the latent space and
then we obtain the first latent variable
and then what you do is that you go to a
second auto encoder in which you will
fix the dimension of the latent space to
two
then you retain that first mode that you
obtained that first latent variable and
you will get a new latent variable with
a lower contribution towards the
reconstruction of the original signal so
you can do that recursively you can have
a hierarchy of autoencoders in such a
way that you have modes or latent
vectors actually which will have less
and less contribution towards the
original signal that
representation will be
optimal but will still not be orthogonal
we want to be able to impose that
orthogonality in some way and that's
where we want to be able to introduce
some stochasticity in our distribution
in the latent space that's how we are
considering the framework of the beta
variation auto encoders
which i'm showing you here
essentially we're going to consider p of
x as a distribution of the original data
and p of r as the distribution of the
data in the latent space
so knowing this what we want to do is
that we want to
maximize this quantity over here which
is the marginal likelihood this is
essentially the approximation of the
original distribution
with the parameters theta of the neural
network and we're going to have two
distributions basically we're going to
have a probabilistic decoder which will
take us from the latent space to the
original space and because this latent
space is um given by a certain
distribution
this is going to be a generative model
we're going to produce samples in that
from that latent to that original space
and the other distribution that we have
is the one at the bottom which goes from
the original to the latent space and
this is a probabilistic encoder or in
other words this is a recognition model
okay
so having this what we can actually do
is that we can uh well we know that our
uh distribution the latent space um is
given by a gaussian distribution so we
have uh we are able to sample from it
and we are actually going to add a
random noise given by a gaussian
distribution this is that epsilon that
you can see over here
to be able to get those samples in that
in that latent space
what we can actually show is that beta
variational auto encoders can have this
loss function that you can see here at
the bottom where this parameter beta and
this is
basically a penalization factor that
will allow us to promote learning
statistically independent variables in
the latent space and this is done
by basically minimizing the distance
between p of r which is the distribution
of the latent space and the product of
its marginals and that's quite cool
because in the end this will give us two
nice properties you will be promoting
learning quantities in the latent space
that are statistically independent
and at the same time we will be also
promoting a lower size of the latent
space so we will be able to have more
latent variables that are zero
so the goal is to have a decent angle
and parsimonious laden space
this is interesting because of course
all of this happens in the latent space
right these variables are going to be
as statistically independent as possible
but when you decode them and look at
them in the physical space you will be
able to see
the spatial modes
and we will show you soon how um
orthogonal actually those um those modes
in physical space can actually be
so
this is actually
quite
promising as a statistical approach i'm
showing you here at the bottom that's
the encoder so we are going from the
original space through the successive
reduction of dimension until reaching
the latent space where you can see the
mean the standard deviation and also the
noise so this is where we sample from
then at the top i'm showing you the
decoder and the decoder is of course the
model that is taking us from the latent
space to the original space again to the
physical one so that's basically the
idea we want to
combine what we know about our latent
space so we can produce these most in
physical
space that are actually
non-linear but
try to have those properties of
orthogonality and optimality
so essentially
if we look at the reconstruction atoms
basically an instantaneous flow field
and this is again the flow between the
two obstacles here is the reference and
you can get an idea of how the turbulent
fluctuations look like
and i'm going to show you the
reconstruction in four different
reduced order model approaches right
here at the bottom you have the pod so
this is how much energy you reconstruct
with only five modes it turns out you
want to reconstruct around 30 percent
obviously the field that you obtain is
quite filtered and attenuated compared
to the original data and the other three
panels show the reconstruction with the
outer encoder based approaches all of
them around 90 percent of the
reconstruction
this one over here is the one that comes
from the beta vae from the beta
variation auto encoder
so here
on this panel over here i'm showing you
a detailed view of the flow between the
two obstacles so you can see for
instance these regions of a strong
fluctuation both positive and negative
and you can see that the pod is not
really able to to capture those regions
of a strong fluctuation both
positive and negative whereas all the
autoencoder based approaches are able to
actually capture with only five modes
which is a very very small regional
model we're actually able to capture
such a distribution of strong
fluctuations
positive and negative right so that's
basically
an interesting power that we can get
from all these autoencoder approaches
what we can actually learn now is how
helpful those approaches are when it
comes to
being able to impose interesting
physical properties in our radiosolar
model what i'm showing you here is the
determinant of the cross correlation
matrix so that's basically in physical
space how correlated the um
basically the different modes are and of
course the pod has a hundred percent
orthogonality because by design these
modes need to be orthogonal and what you
can see on this panel is the beta
variation auto encoder which has over 99
percent of tonality so we are succeeding
quite well at um being able to produce
modes that are orthogonal in our
physical space there are two approaches
and the autoencoder
based on cnns and the hierarchical route
encoder they are both having much less
orthogonality so those modes are not
going to be orthogonal which has
problems in the context of orthogonality
and interpretability but also problems
when it comes to trying to have a
parsimonious model right
so this is an interesting property
actually it seems that we are able to
have quite orthogonal modes that's
encouraging
and what i'm showing you here is the
effect of the parameter beta so that's
basically the penalization that we are
introducing to
promote learning those statistical
independent values so what you can see
in this panel is that for a larger value
of beta what you have is of course a
larger value of the orthogonality so
quite high
but
the
reconstruction goes down right so we are
having essentially
the possibility of reconstructing less
energy if we have more orthogonal modes
and that's of course natural right
because our loss function
is aiming at having a very good
reconstruction that's the first term of
the loss function but also we are trying
to introduce another term to promote
orthogonality and you cannot have it all
at the same time right so that means
that
we are increasing beta we are promoting
more orthogonal modes that means that we
get less reconstruction which in
practice would mean that i would need
more modes
to be able to have a proper
reconstruction of a good level of energy
from the original signal
in practice what it means is that we can
still have quite compact uh reduced
models with outer encoders
while also retaining the nice property
of the orthogonality
what i'm showing you here is
essentially a summary of how those modes
look like okay so let's start with the
second column
here is the pod so these are the first
five pod modes you can see of course
that being orthogonal they are able to
exhibit quite some interesting physical
features in fact in the first modes you
can see a large scale shading
characteristic of this type of
flows around obstacles
in these two columns i'm showing you the
outer encoder based on cnns and also the
outer color based on cns that is also
hierarchical and what you can see is
that you have basically a bunch of high
and low frequencies but you don't really
see any distinct features that are
physical that can be really understood
as something that helps us to learn
something about the physics what is
interesting if we look at the first
column over here which is the beta
variation out encoder
is that these modes are actually
exhibiting the same shading mechanism
that is identified by the pod modes
so that's actually the key here we are
able to have modes that
are well associated with physical
phenomena they can be interpretable they
can help us to have a quite parsimonious
latent representation of the system
and at the same time we can embed those
uh non-linearities there right so we can
have these modes that are connected in a
non-linear way to be able to represent
the original data what is also
interesting if we come here and now we
compare the pod modes and then the
encoder ones and the vita variation out
encoder ones you see that we identified
basically the same large scale features
but we had a lot of high frequency and
basically this would be components that
are turbulent fluctuations closely
connected with those large scale
features that we see over there so we
are able to have the dominant physical
mechanisms and superimpose on those we
have those trolling fluctuations
that essentially help us to build a
model that is much more compact compared
to the pod so with five modes we can
actually
build a very nice representation of the
system and one last property that i
mentioned the optimality that's also
something that we can obtain with a beta
variation out encoder modes so what we
would do in the case of the beta ba is
is that we would
reconstruct the signal based on one of
the latent vectors making all the other
zero
recursively we would see the first mode
that gives us the largest reconstruction
and then we would be adding a second one
by making all the other zero a third one
in such a way that iteratively we can
come up with a combination of modes that
give us the largest reconstruction
we can therefore rank these modes so we
can recover the optimality property and
of course maintaining the nice property
of the orthogonality so in practice what
we show in this reference as you can see
here is that we can
well basically propose a methodology for
um
optimal and orthogonal nonlinear modal
decompositions into rule and flows we
showed it in a case that is reasonably
complex with 3d it's turbulent we have
quite some
complexity to be able to model there
and we believe that this can be a very
promising approach to be able to
build drums that are compact and can be
helpful in quite complex rule and flows
so i would like to thank you very much
for your attention today this is my
contact information so of course i'll be
very happy to discuss more to answer all
your questions here's my my email the
web of my love the universal app and
also my social media so please feel free
to contact me and i'll be very happy to
discuss more with you thank you very
much